elle gère les lycées les transports les
déchets les subventions aux entreprises
ou encore l'installation de votre fibre
les régions jouent un rôle absolument
crucial dans notre vie quotidienne
et pourtant les élections régionales ne
semble pas passionner les français
alors pourquoi beauty lé ces élections
le parti de l'abstention et il l'unique
parti gagnant réponse dans facture
[Musique]
regardez cette courbe cela fait 35 ans
que nous votons pour élire les
représentants des régions et depuis 1986
les français se sont rendus six fois
dans les urnes
pourtant le taux d'abstention augmentent
presque à chaque élection pour celle de
ce sont les mandats de 1700 conseillers
régionaux qu'il faut renouveler et selon
un sondage lci le figaro du 13 juin
rien qu'en ile de france près de 58% des
électeurs franciliens n'aurait pas prévu
de se déplacer jusque dans les urnes
un chiffre qui monte jusqu'à 73% pour
les moins de 35 ans
c'est vrai quel paradoxe les élus locaux
sont à la fois les élus qui ont investi
ce qui sont investis le plus fortement
de la confiance et des français la
politique au quotidien vous savez la
politique qui règle les problèmes de la
vie de tous les jours et en même temps
les taux de participation qui sont plus
celles la participation faible n'est pas
l'apanage des élections régionales où
des élections départementales
nous l'avons eu aux élections
législatives en 2007 et depuis 2002 les
taux d'abstention aux élections
législatives sont assez importants
tâchons toutefois de rester prudent avec
les sondages surtout lorsqu'il concerne
les intentions de vote des citoyens lors
de ces fameuses régionales pourquoi
d'abord parce qu'il est assez difficile
de comprendre très concrètement à quoi
servent ces élections régionales pour
beaucoup de français ce sont des
élections assez flou on est un peu dans
un autre 2 c'est pas tout à fait des
élections locales c'est pas des
élections nationales
il ya des personnalités qui se présente
à lui président présidente de région qui
sont en même temps des candidats
potentiels à l'élection présidentielle
et c'est vrai que là aussi c'est
difficile pour les français de bien
situer et de bien on va dire de bien
capter la problématique de ces élections
le problème c'est qu'il y ait une telle
concentration de l'attention de la
mobilisation politique sur l'élection
présidentielle que ça se fait aussi au
détriment des autres formes de scrutin
l'abstention n'est évidemment pas un
phénomène nouveau loin de là et souvent
ne pas voter est corrélée à une
situation sociale plus fragiles parfois
plus précaires ou un niveau d'éducation
un petit peu moins élevé lors des
régionales il semblerait que cette
tendance soit multipliée voire amplifier
les catégories sociales qui
habituellement participerait l'élection
présidentielle et qui là n'ont pas
participé aux élections régionales et
puis une deuxième motivation de
l'abstention c'est une motivation
politique c'est à dire c'est le manque
de politisation le manque d'intérêt pour
la chose publique et il faut dire que
les français ne sont pas vraiment aidé
ce qu'il manque selon bruno cautrès
c'est une véritable confrontation des
idées et une meilleure offre politique
parle pas de la culture du clash telle
qu'on la voit aujourd'hui trop souvent
sur les réseaux sociaux ou des plateaux
de télévision
ico bon sens du terme c'est à dire avoir
des programmes contrasté qui se
présentent aux électeurs comme des
alternatives qui sont nuisibles
vous savez que beaucoup d'électeurs non
à l'otan vous intéressez au programme
politique
bref faire son boulot deux candidats et
faciliter la tâche de l'électeur
depuis trente ans les régions gagnent
pourtant de plus en plus de pouvoir
réseau de transport formation
professionnelle gestion des universités
ou encore du développement durable mais
ces thématiques n'ont pas toujours été
au coeur des campagnes politiques
c'est vraiment quelque chose est à
regretter parce que s'il y avait
vraiment une opportunité à saisir
aujourd'hui en france c'était cette
opportunité nous avons traversé au cours
des trois dernières années deux crises
majeures en france la crise des gilets
jaunes la crise du coc bide de crise qui
ont en commun de souligner la difficulté
pour le modèle français
lorsque la décision publique vient d'en
haut on a beaucoup dit au cours de ces
deux crises qu'il s'agissait de
ressources et la démocratie française de
redonner aux français confiance dans la
politique et dans l'action pluie en
partant du bas
en partant de ce qui est le plus proche
d'eux donc on peut que relever regretté
que ces élections régionales n'est pas
vraiment donné l'occasion d'un grand
débat national sur qu'est-ce que les
régions font aujourd'hui que les
départements ne sont pas qu'est ce que
les régions font que les métropoles et
les villes ne font pas est ce qu'il y a
au cours des années qui arrivent pour la
france et conclusions à retirer sur son
modèle de la décision en allant vers
plus de régionalisation et il est
possible que les régionales soit comme
les municipales en 2020 une victime
collatérale du co lead la crise qu vide
elle a plutôt aujourd'hui eu un effet
d'annuler le débat politique
les esprits restent aussi très marquée
par le contexte des élections
municipales de l'an dernier qui avait vu
le début de la crise pandémique
certains français ont conservé quand
même l'idée que s'il y avait pu avoir
des contaminations
finalement ce qui pourrait donner
vraiment envie aux citoyens c'est de
comprendre tout simplement ce que fait
la région pour lui et sa famille
en termes d'infrastructures
hospitalières routière ou de création
d'emploi par exemple ce qui semble bien
plus motivant au fond il s'agit surtout
de faire en sorte que les citoyens
trouve de l'intérêt ira sans aucun doute
matière à beaucoup réfléchir à l'issue
de ces élections régionales si
l'abstention atteint les sommets que les
sondages pré-électoraux l'huile
prédisent pour le moment
[Musique]